2004 miami hurricanes had six players
taken in round one of the draft that is
a record alabama and lsu both have over
under odds of five and a half players to
be taken in round one so if you go over
by that point five you're at six and you
match the 2004 hurricanes who's more
likely to do it chris alabama or lsu
uh i think i look at alabama probably
more likely to do it if they were gonna
break the record right i could see
all six of those guys i don't know if
the running back from lsu goes in the
first round but i look at alabama and go
tua judy ruggs wills
uh treyvon diggs xavier mckinney i think
all have really really great chances of
going in the first round they're gonna
go in the first round is what i'm saying
and then you have a guy like terrell
lewis who's a first round talent but had
some injury issues in his college career
so he'll be borderline
and i think a guy you did the interview
with the other day mike raquan davis i
think he goes somewhere between 20 and
32. so i'm gonna take alabama i look at
rayquan davis and see like a guy like
mohammed wilkerson or richard seymour
that type of specimen i have a hard time
thinking he doesn't get picked in the
first round either so i my money's on
bama if it does get broken
well and it just makes [ __ ] when you see
that many great players headed for the
draft it makes you wonder why the team
didn't do better last year but we've
seen that from time to time with teams
far less accomplished remember when
there was a there was a stretch when
north carolina state was like a first
round draft pick factory it's like how
in the heck did north carolina state not
have a better team when les miles was a
coach at lsu when you think of all the
talent they had and the guys who went on
to become first-round picks like how did
they not do better as a team when he was
there so there's really not a strong
correlation not as strong as you would
think either way alabama and lsu among
the best programs in the country and not
a surprise that both of them are in
contention to tie miami you don't think
anybody's going to get the seven do you
this is just a matter of tying miami at
six i i think it is i i i look at it
i think they could get to seven i think
i do think alabama could get to seven
when i look at the overall list i think
a little bit's gonna be dependent
on like i said rayquan davis and trevon
diggs uh uh but
yeah i think there's a chance mike i do
because i think will's tua mckinney judy
rugg are all gonna go in the first round
for sure i think diggs goes in the first
round too and then it becomes one of
those pat the pass rusher lewis or
raekwon davis for that last spot
hey and
when all else fails i think the bottom
line is
no off-season program this year going to
require a lot of self-discipline those
guys from alabama more likely to have
the self-discipline no doubt upon their
time working with nick saban maybe that
breaks the top
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports